In this problem, we're considering droplets of water that have a mass of 1 gram here,
and they're falling a distance of 1.5 m.
When we measured their final speed, we found that they were going at 4 m/s,
which is less than we expect.
Now we have to figure out how much work was done by air resistance
in order to slow down this 1 g drop of water to 4 m/s.
The first thing we know is that the total work done on the drop of water
must be equal to its change in kinetic energy.
That's just the work-energy theorem. What's the total work equal to?
Well, it's just equal to the work done by gravity minus the work done by friction.
We know that the work done by gravity is just equal to
the force of gravity times the distance it acts over,
and we also know that the change in kinetic energy is just equal to
the final kinetic energy minus the original kinetic energy.
Since the drops starts at rest, we know that they have no original kinetic energy.
This term we can cross out.
Now we can plug in mg for the force of gravity,
and we can use 1/2 mv final squared for the final kinetic energy.
Solving for the work done by friction, I get this equation here.
Finally, when I plug in all my numbers here,
I get that the work done by friction on a single drop of water has to be equal to 0.007 J.                                     Good job.